en este vídeo vamos a pegar la base de
nuestra lámpara adherible y vamos a unir
los cables de nuestros motores y
nuestras baterías para que podamos
conectarlos a las partes de nuestro
robot que los necesitan
pasamos por estos huecos los cables de
nuestros motores y es importante que
alineamos bien estos huecos vemos que la
base tiene tres agujeros y vamos a
asegurarnos que los cables estén bien
alineados con estos huecos asegurémonos
de que los cables pasan por completo por
los agujeros y ya que tenemos estos bien
alineados podemos doblarlos para que no
nos estorben tenemos que asegurarnos que
todo quede bien centrado y bien alineado
como queremos la base de la lámpara
tiene una cinta de doble cara
así que quitamos el plástico que la
cubre y ya que la tenemos alineada como
queremos de nuevo nos aseguramos que
quede bien centrada con nuestros motores
y nuestras baterías y la presionamos
para que quede bien pegada con estos y
que
en su lugar bien centrada si no está
centrada entonces puede que las ruedas
rocen un lado y nos causen problemas así
que debemos asegurarnos que la base está
bien centrada ya tenemos nuestros cables
del motor y ahora vamos a conectar los
cables de las baterías estos cables
tienen que pasar por los mismos agujeros
que los del motor del lado derecho y
ahora ponemos nuestro conector para
baterías de 9 voltios algo importante es
que cuando ponemos nuestro colector de
baterías de 9 voltios es que tenemos que
darnos cuenta de que ya va la corriente
eléctrica pasando por estos cables y ya
que los extremos de ambos cables tienen
la misma longitud pues podrían terminar
tocándose lo que ocasionaría un
cortocircuito y todo se calentaría
demasiado y nos daría muchos problemas
por lo que vamos a cubrir uno de los
extremos de un cable para que al
conectar la batería pues no haya un
cortocircuito y se sobrecaliente el
sistema y arruinen nuestra batería
así que asegúrense de siempre cubrir un
extremo antes de conectar la batería ya
hemos conectado un lado y ahora vamos a
conectar el otro lado de nuevo usaremos
un conector para batería de 9 voltios y
lo ponemos por el hueco vacío ya que es
el que está más cercano a la otra
batería no olviden cubrir un extremo
antes de conectarlo lo ponemos por el
hueco de enfrente ya que queda más cerca
del lado de la otra batería y es así
como colocamos los cables de los motores
y las baterías